it is june 13 2022 and you're watching
the code report things move fast on the
world wide web just a few months ago web
3 was all the rage but then bitcoin
crashed 50 and if t sales collapsed the
pawns economics of tokens like luna
stopped working and even networks like
celsius and exchanges like binance are
not letting people get their money out
this is all totally normal and nothing
to be concerned about at all the lambos
are still coming now if you haven't been
paying attention we've already moved
ahead to web5 because just the other day
billionaire jack dorsey steamrolled
right over web 4 and announced web 5
which they're calling the decentralized
web platform like most people you might
be thinking that this announcement is
satire
[Laughter]
are you serious but apparently they're
totally serious about it it's being
developed by the blockhead unit at block
formerly square and the idea is to
provide a decentralized internet layer
based on bitcoin's lightning network
where users own and control their data
and have a wallet just like web3 that
can connect their identity to any app
without needing to sign up and
explicitly share their data with the
host app when it comes to app developers
instead of building pwas you would build
dwas where the web app is not served by
a centralized app server most likely
owned by amazon google or microsoft but
rather a decentralized node owned by
some other user on the network most
notably though there will be no tokens
involved other than bitcoin itself that
means end users won't have to worry
about investing in all these different
[ __ ] coins like this one called ethereum
that went from 4 800 to 1200 in just a
few months not to mention the insane gas
fees that you have to pay just to
perform trivial transactions with web3
and as many critics have pointed out the
current state of web 3 is not
decentralized at all but rather
controlled by a small number of vcs and
silicon valley insiders it's unfortunate
because decentralization is a really
awesome concept for the web you don't
actually need cryptocurrency to make it
work you just need a bunch of people
participating and benefiting from the
system bittorrent has been doing this
for file sharing long before bitcoin was
even a thing now the funny thing about
web 5 is that it's being spearheaded by
jack dorsey a ceo with an excellent
track record of not caring about your
speech privacy or freedom you're a big
fat
like you wouldn't want mark zuckerberg
to be king of the metaverse in the same
way you definitely don't want jack
dorsey to be king of web 5. personally
i'm putting all my bets on web 6 which
is already under development by snoop
dogg this has been the code report
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one